-President Trump has settled
on his closing argument
for the midterms --
lying about healthcare,
immigration,
and a made-up tax cut.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]
-After a series
of explosive devices
was sent to prominent Democrats
and CNN yesterday,
President Trump
flew to Wisconsin
to campaign for GOP
Senate candidate Leah Vukmir.
You could tell Trump
was trying to restrain himself.
In fact, throughout the rally,
he kept bragging to the crowd
about how nice he was being.
-The Democrats
are for higher taxes,
more regulation, and more
top-down government control.
[ Audience booing ]
And by the way, do you see
how nice I'm behaving tonight?
This is, like --
Have you ever seen this?
We're all behaving very well.
And, hopefully,
we can keep it that way, right?
[ Cheering ]
We're gonna keep it that way.
Leah's radical, far-left
opponent is Tammy Baldwin...
[ Audience booing ]
...who wants a socialist
takeover of healthcare.
[ Audience booing ]
You know, I'm trying
to say that very nicely.
I'm trying to --
[ Laughter ]
See, normally I'd scream,
"They want
a socialist takeover."
Now I say,
"Wants a socialist takeover."
[ Laughter ]
I'm trying to be nice.
-Man, low-energy Trump
is so weird.
[ Laughter ]
It's like --
[ Applause ]
It's like seeing
that neighborhood dog
who's always digging
through everyone's trash
suddenly moping around
with a cone on his head.
[ Laughter ]
Hey, maybe don't make it clear
that being nice
wasn't your first choice.
You're like a cannibal
who wants credit
for just licking people's faces.
[ Laughter ]
"Isn't it great
that I haven't taken a bite?"
[ Laughter ]
You're an adult.
you don't get credit
for doing something
adults are supposed to do.
Someone sent bombs to several
major political figures,
and Trump's acting like a kid
whose parents forced him
to wear a suit
for the family Christmas photo.
I'm surprised he didn't
end the rally
by turning to Mike Pence
and saying,
"I was nice!
Can I have my ice cream now?!"
[ Laughter ]
Also, listen to Trump --
[ Applause ]
Listen to Trump's
impression of himself.
It's almost like
he knows how crazy he is.
-See, normally I'd scream,
"They want
a socialist takeover!"
Now I say,
"Wants a socialist takeover."
-I've said it before,
and I'll say it again --
Donald Trump has the best
Donald Trump impression.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
"Have you guys --
Have you guys ever noticed
that thing
where I'm all, like, crazy?"
[ Laughter ]
This rally was just
the latest in a series
Trump has been doing
to campaign for Republicans
in the closing days
before the midterms.
Now, if there's one refrain
you hear more than any other
at these rallies,
it's his false claim
that he's accomplished more
than any president in history.
But tellingly,
Republicans are not actually
talking about any of those
supposed accomplishments.
Just take their signature
piece of legislation,
the massive tax cut they gave
to corporations and the wealthy.
That tax cut is so unpopular
that rather than campaign on it,
Trump is just making up
a completely new tax cut
specifically for
the middle class
that he claims Republicans
are about to pass.
-We are looking at putting in
a very major tax cut
for middle-income people.
And if we do that,
it'll be sometime just prior,
I would say, to November.
We are going to be putting in,
and are studying
very deeply right now,
round the clock, a major tax cut
for middle-income people.
-What was
the timeframe for that?
-I would say sometime
around the 1st of November,
maybe a little before that.
-I'll give Trump credit
for one thing --
he doesn't overwhelm you
with the details.
[ Laughter ]
"We're gonna maybe
do a tax cut pretty soon.
Maybe Novemberuary...
[ Laughter ]
...ish."
So Trump says Republicans
are gonna introduce
a major middle-class tax cut
prior to November,
which sounds great,
except for the fact
that Congress is out of session
until after the November 6th
midterm elections.
So there
are two possibilities here.
Either Trump is lying,
or he doesn't know
how Congress works.
And, honestly,
it's probably both.
[ Laughter ]
If you're ever --
[ Cheers and applause ]
If you're ever asking yourself,
"Is Trump lying
or is he stupid?"
The answer is most likely,
"C," all of the above.
[ Laughter ]
And yet Trump keeps repeating
this obvious fabrication,
hoping voters will hear it
and think Republicans
are actually going
to cut their taxes.
In fact, here's an exchange
Trump had with reporters
this week where they tried
to explain to him
that what he was saying
made no sense.
I'm gonna read
the transcript for you.
Here it is.
"You said that you wanted
tax cuts by November 1st.
Congress isn't even in session.
How is that possible?"
"No, we're going
to be passing --
No, no, we're putting in
a resolution sometime
in the next week
or week and a half, two weeks."
"A resolution where?"
"We're going to put in.
We're giving a middle-income
tax reduction of about 10%."
"Are you signing
an executive order for that?"
"No, no, no,
I'm going through Congress."
"But Congress isn't in session,
though.
We won't have time
to do the vote."
"We'll do the vote later."
"Congress is out."
"We'll do the vote
after the election."
It's like
an Abbott and Costello routine
where Trump is Abbott
and Costello,
and the theater has a gas leak.
[ Applause ]
That transcript is like
listening to your grandpa
talk to the cable guy.
[ Laughter ]
"I'm trying
to change the channel."
"Sir, your TV's not on."
"Yes, it is."
"What channel are you watching?"
"The snowy channel."
[ Laughter ]
Trump then repeated the same lie
at a rally in Texas
later that day,
and as he was talking about it,
he tried to ask
the Congressman in charge
of tax policy, Kevin Brady,
who was in the crowd if what
he was saying was accurate.
-We're gonna putting in
a 10% tax cut
for middle-income families.
It's going to be
put in next year.
You talk about help with taxes,
and so, Kevin,
we're putting in next week
the 10% reduction
in middle-income taxes, right?
Next week.
-"We're putting in
next week, right?
No?
Why?
Oh! Because Congress
is out of session.
But why?
Oh, they're campaigning!
For what?
Oh! Congress."
[ Laughter ]
"What's that?"
But Trump --
[ Applause ]
Trump isn't just lying...
Trump isn't just lying
about stuff he hasn't done.
He's also lying about stuff
he has done,
like his attempts
to repeal Obamacare,
which protects people
with pre-existing conditions.
Remember, this has been
the defining fight
of the last decade of politics.
Republicans have spent 10 years
promising and then trying
to repeal Obamacare.
And yet, and perhaps the most
brazen lie of his presidency,
Trump tweeted yesterday
and repeated again today
the false claim that Republicans
will protect
pre-existing conditions.
-Quote, "Republicans
will totally protect people
with pre-existing conditions.
Democrats will not.
Vote Republican."
-We will always
protect Americans
with pre-existing conditions.
Always.
-Dude, you just spent two years
trying to repeal the damn thing.
We saw you.
You held a party
in the Rose Garden to celebrate.
Do you remember?
It was you
and the cast of "Cocoon."
[ Laughter ]
I mean, look at how many
old, white dudes are there.
[ Applause ]
All they need
is an acoustic guitar
and that press conference
could've doubled
as a Viagra commercial.
[ Laughter ]
And not only did the GOP try
repeatedly to repeal Obamacare,
the administration
is currently backing a lawsuit
that seeks to overturn Obamacare
and its protections
for people
with pre-existing conditions.
And yet, in spite of this,
Trump and GOP candidates
across the country have been
lying through their teeth,
claiming that they will maintain
those protections.
-We can protect
pre-existing conditions,
and you need to understand,
everyone agrees we're gonna
protect pre-existing conditions.
-We can protect people
with pre-existing conditions
in the state without protecting
the failure that is Obamacare.
-I am passionate
about protecting people
with pre-existing conditions
and forcing insurance companies
to provide them
health insurance.
-I support
forcing insurance companies
to cover all
pre-existing conditions.
-We support
taking care of people
with pre-existing conditions.
I've said it before,
I'll say it again --
I'll fall in front of a truck
before I let people
go without coverage
for pre-existing conditions.
-Oh, well, lucky for you,
falling in front of a truck
is covered under Obamacare.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
So, in the closing days
of the campaign,
Trump and the GOP
are lying brazenly
about healthcare
and a made-up tax cut.
And if all that fails,
Trump's fallback plan
is to scare the crap
out of people
by lying about immigration.
In fact, we're seeing that
all over this country.
Republicans are fear-mongering
about immigration,
appealing to racial paranoia,
and, in some cases,
running explicitly
racist campaigns
against their
Democratic opponents,
which is why it was so cathartic
to watch this amazing exchange
yesterday from Florida's
gubernatorial debate
between Democrat Andrew Gillum
and Republican Ron DeSantis.
-Mr. DeSantis has spoken.
Hey, first of all,
he's got Neo-Nazis
helping him out in this state.
He has spoken
at racist conferences.
He's accepted a contribution
and would not return it
from someone
who referred to
the former President
of the United States
as a Muslim n-----.
When asked to return that money,
he said no.
He's using that money
to now fund negative ads.
Now, I'm not calling
Mr. DeSantis a racist.
I'm simply saying the racists
believe he's a racist.
[ Laughter ]
-If I may appropriate some
black culture for just a moment.
Oh, snap.
[ Laughter and applause ]
I really...
[ Applause ]
I really hope Republicans
are right about healthcare,
because after a hit like that,
that dude's gonna have
a pre-existing condition.
[ Laughter ]
That debate should have gone
by "Mortal Kombat" rules.
-I'm simply saying the racists
believe he's a racist.
-Finish him!
[ Laughter ]
-Seriously.
Look at that guy's face.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Anytime someone makes that face,
it should be accompanied
by this sound.
[ Pac-Man dying sound ]
Think about what it says
that, after two years in power,
all Republicans can do
is lie about healthcare,
make up a fictional tax cut,
and try to terrify people about
a group of vulnerable migrants
slowly walking
toward the border.
They've had two years to govern
and nothing to show for it.
I'd say a lot worse
than that but...
-I'm trying to be nice.
-This has been
"A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]